follow Lange focus on Facebook Twitter
and Instagram hello everyone welcome to
the Lange focused Channel and my name is
Paul
today we'll be answering the question
how similar are Spanish and Italian
Spanish and Italian are both members of
the Romance language family which
developed from dialects of vulgar latin
which were spoken throughout the Roman
Empire for more information on their
history and development check out my
video on the Romance language family
right here like any pair of Romance
languages Spanish and Italian have a lot
in common and they are mutually
intelligible to some extent especially
in their written form and when spoken
slowly and clearly
some speakers of Spanish and Italian
report that they are able to have
extended conversations with speakers of
the other language provided that they
both speak slowly and clearly and they
stop to clarify unfamiliar vocabulary
but despite their similarity spanish and
italian are also different in many ways
let's examine both of the languages
together and we'll see just what's
similar and different about them
vocabulary spanish and italian have
about 82% lexical similarity that means
that 82% of the words in either language
will have cognate vocabulary in the
other language let's look at some
examples of spanish and italian cognates
in italian Giardino and in spanish
Hannah Dean and these mean garden in
Italian postal and in Spanish West oh
this means place in Italian Theo de and
in Spanish floor this means flower in
Italian probable a and in Spanish
probably this means probable or likely
in Italian potahto
and in Spanish poetical this means port
those pairs of words are quite obvious
cognates let's look at a couple of less
obvious cognates as well in Italian
figlio in Spanish equal in Italian kiawe
in Spanish yelling in Italian Casa and
in Spanish
Casa now let's look at a couple of
sentences to see how many of the words
are similar first in Spanish still a
yendo un buen Libra and in Italian
stolid Gendo unborn libro this means I'm
read
good book so in these two sentences all
of the vocabulary is equivalent or
cognate another example in Spanish
necesito cambia un poco de dinero in
Italian Oh Bassanio de cambio de un
Fawlty salty these sentences mean I need
to change a little money the way to
express need is different in the two
sentences in Spanish it's necesito and
in Italian it's obisam no D in Spanish
the way to say a little is un poco in
Italian it's wooden pole in Italian you
can also say un poco which is correct
but it's more common to say goonpo
next the preposition like of is de in
Spanish and it's D in Italian the word
for money is D NATO in Spanish and it's
salty in Italian so in this case you can
see that some of the vocabulary is the
same or equivalent but not all of it and
one more example in Spanish dingleq
England item ankle and in Italian de
votre vie de una banca these sentences
mean I need to find a bank in these
sentences we see need expressed in
different ways than in the last pair of
sentences in Spanish it's tengo que
while in Italian it's devil but in
Spanish it's also possible to say de
Bowl an obvious cognate of duvall the
word meaning to find is also different
in Spanish it's income trod but in
Italian it's Truvada
actually the Spanish word can also mean
to meet and there's a different Italian
word in cantata which is a cognate of
encontrada but it only means to meet not
to find next you can see that the words
for bank are cognates but interestingly
they have different gender in Spanish
it's masculine which we can see from the
article una and the o at the end of
Banco and in Italian it's feminine which
we can see from the article una and the
a at the end of banca so from these
examples we can see that there's a lot
of crossover between Spanish vocabulary
and Italian vocabulary but there are
also some false friends to watch out for
false friends
no I don't mean two-faced people who
talk behind your back I mean words that
look and sound similar in either
language and likely share a common
origin but they have a different meaning
or usage in each language for example in
Spanish pronto means soon in Italian
Toronto means ready in Spanish where
that means to keep or to guard in
Italian Guara Dada
means to look at in Spanish of shekinah
means office in Italian of fee Gina
means workshop there's a different word
in Italian Rufio which means office in
Spanish in bana fatih means pregnant but
in Italian Umbra Tata means embarassed
false friends like these are a common
source of confusion for people who learn
a language that's similar to one they
already know if we only look at lexical
similarity Spanish has more in common
with Portuguese than it does with
Italian and Italian has more in common
with French than it does with Spanish in
either case it's 89% lexical similarity
but Spanish and Italian are more similar
in pronunciation than those other pairs
of languages which can sometimes lead to
more intelligibility pronunciation
Spanish has five vowel sounds ah II ooh
ay Oh Italian also has these five vowel
sounds plus two additional ones Italian
has two esau n--'s open e at like the
e'en bed and closed e a like the vowel
sound in say it also has two Oh sounds
open oh ah like the Owen pop and the
closed o sound Oh like the Owen Pope and
both Spanish and Italian have a similar
Rohtak R sound the one notable
difference between Spanish and Italian
pronunciation is that almost all Italian
words end in a vowel but in Spanish this
is not the case for example in Italian
coast Adi which means to cost but in
Spanish its cost that so the Italian
word ends in a vowel while the Spanish
word ends in a consonant if you watch
out for this you'll notice it quite a
lot pronunciation and orthography in
both Spanish and Italian C&G becomes
soft when followed by I or II but the
soft sound is different in each language
in Spanish the soft C sounds like tha or
sup in Italian it sounds like Chuck in
Spanish this
gee sounds like huh in Italian it sounds
like Jo for example in Spanish see you
that and in Italian
Cheeta this means City in Spanish and it
means people but in Italian it's gentei
in Spanish canina means general in
Italian it's generally some words like
those above or cognates that sound
different there are other words that
sound more similar would have to be
written differently to reflect their
sound the word for what in Spanish is
que spelt with qu and in Italian it's K
spelt with ch in Spanish if you want to
have a hard C sound before I or II you
have to spell it as qu in Italian you
have to spell it as CH and while CH
always represents a hard C sound in
Italian in Spanish it represents the
sound cha like in English so in Italian
you have cioccolato
spelled with CI at the beginning but in
Spanish you have chocolate they spelled
with ch in Spanish you have cuando
meaning when and quantal meaning how
much and in Italian you have quando and
quantal in Spanish you can't write it
with qu because that always represents a
hard C sound so the words would end up
sounding like kondal and canto some of
the differences in pronunciation and
orthography between Spanish and Italian
are fairly systematic for example e in
Italian often becomes ie in Spanish for
example temple becomes tiempo dente
becomes the end day and when in Italian
you have SC SF or SP or s T at the
beginning of a word in Spanish these are
often preceded by an e for example
skreever in Italian becomes s kediri in
Spanish and specially in Italian becomes
a speciale in Spanish one other thing to
note is that double consonants are very
common in Italian but in Spanish most
consonants can't be doubled for example
in Italian gato means cat but in Spanish
it's gato and in Italian tatse means cup
but it's dasa in Spanish grammar the
general word order of Spanish and
Italian is very similar have a look at
these two sentences
in Spanish el Nakamura con nosotros
manana in Italian lui no man Jericho no
Edo money you can see that there's some
different vocabulary but the sentences
are translatable word for word notice
that in both languages the subject
pronoun is normally optional because the
verb is conjugated for person and number
another example in Spanish less Crotona
kata in Italian Leo screech Oh in
Electra this means I wrote him a letter
so here the word order is still exactly
the same and notice that the object
pronoun comes before the conjugated verb
in this case the auxiliary verb in both
languages Italian grammar has a couple
of complications that Spanish doesn't
have articles articles in Italian are
more complicated than in Spanish in
Spanish the indefinite articles are une
for masculine nouns and una for feminine
nouns also an Italian it's UN and una
but soon becomes uno before words
beginning in s or Z followed by another
consonant and una becomes apostrophe
before a noun beginning with a vowel so
in Italian we have wouldn't pass Oporto
but who knows - dente and we have una
kiawe but moon italiana Spanish and
Italian both have four basic definite
articles in Spanish they are L for
masculine singular la for feminine
singular loss for masculine plural less
feminine plural in Italian they're ill
for masculine singular la for feminine
singular e for masculine plural and lei
for feminine plural but Neil becomes low
before words beginning with s or Z plus
another consonant and it becomes L '
before a vowel and it becomes a ye
before s or Z plus another consonant so
we have El Paso por todo but law student
it which are both masculine singular and
we have epass support T but Li student e
which are both masculine plural also
both LA and lei become L ' before a
vowel possessive pronouns the way
possessive pronouns are used is also a
little bit different in Italian
possessive pronouns are normally used
together with a definite article except
when we talk about family members but in
Spanish the definite article is not
required
so in Italian you have Lamia Beach
eclipta and it's Spanish you have music
later so notice in Spanish there's no
definite article la another difference
to notice here is that in Spanish there
is no distinction between masculine and
feminine possessive pronouns in Italian
there's Mia for feminine singular and
mio for masculine singular but in
Spanish there's just me for both verbs
the verb tense is used and the way that
verbs are conjugated is really quite
similar in both languages of course the
exact conjugations are not quite the
same but they are fairly similar here's
a sentence meaning they will live in New
York the verb to live in Italian is V
Verde and in Spanish it Bevier the
sentence in Italian Lord of Iran oh and
New York in Spanish a huge dividend in
Malaya we can see that the third-person
plural future tense conjugation is
similar but notice that the Italian one
ends in a double consonant and a vowel
now let's look at a sentence in the past
in the present perfect to be precise
this sentence means she bought too many
things in Italian Lea comprado Tropico Z
and in Spanish again a comprado
demosceners questions the present
perfect tense is formed the same way in
both languages first here is the
auxiliary verb meaning to have avere in
Italian Alera in Spanish that's followed
by the past participle of the verb
meaning to buy comprar day in Italian
and combat in Spanish one thing to note
about the present perfect tense is that
in Italian most verbs take the auxiliary
verb avere to have but some verbs take
esterday meaning to be as their
auxiliary verb that's similar to in
French but in Spanish the only auxiliary
verb is a later
meaning to have so in Italian there's a
inter Otto meaning he entered but in
Spanish it's ient rather those are just
a couple of examples but basically all
verb tenses and all verb forms have an
equivalent or a parallel in the other
language bringing it all together let's
just look at a couple more sentences and
see what we find along the way this
sentence means
Maria is less intelligent than her
sister in Spanish Maria is missing de la
gente que su hermana and in Italian
Maria I Meno intelligente de sua Sorella
here we can see that the word order
is the same and we can basically
translate the sentences word-for-word
the third-person female form of the verb
to be is similar but slightly different
the word for less is similar but
slightly different the word for
intelligent is similar but in Spanish
the G sound is softened to a cup while
in Italian it's softened to a jaw and
the Italian word has a doubled L the
preposition used is also different the
possessive pronoun is similar but in
Spanish there is no gender distinction
and the word for sister is different in
the two languages as you can see Spanish
and Italian have a lot of similarities
including basically the same word order
similar grammar a lot of similar
vocabulary and generally speaking
similar pronunciation but there are
still significant differences
particularly in vocabulary pronunciation
and orthography they are different
enough that they are unmistakeably to
different languages but they're similar
enough that there is a certain degree of
mutual intelligibility and that degree
of mutual intelligibility can probably
be greatly increased by studying even
the basics of the other language but
producing the other language accurately
is obviously another matter and that
would require dedicated study okay the
question of the day for native speakers
of Spanish and Italian how well can you
understand the other language both in
speech and in writing and have you ever
tried to converse with a speaker of the
other language using only your native
languages how did that work out and for
learners of Spanish and Italian how much
does your knowledge of one of those
languages help you make sense of the
other let us know in the comments down
below be sure to follow Lange focus on
Facebook Twitter and Instagram and as
always I would like to say thank you to
all of my patreon supporters especially
these ones right here on the screen for
their monthly pledges thank you for
watching and have a nice stay
you
[Music]